et un jour le propriétaire du Ritz
Mohamed El Fayed vous appelle là je
reçois Michael Jackson il faudrait que
tu t'en occupes et il vous demande de
faire la nounou de Michael Jackson en
fait absolument une sorte de garde du
corps
et nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Philippe Sioux
bonsoir bonsoir alors
praticien à l'Hôpital Américain Neuilly
vous avez soigné des grands patrons des
diplomates des princes des stars à
commencer par Michael Jackson ces
histoires vous les racontez dans un
livre intitulé propofol publié aux
éditions léochères et à 20h dans Salut
les Terriens
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir alors praticien à
l'hôpital américain de Neuilly vous êtes
devenus le médecin des stars notamment
de Michael Jackson votre histoire vous
la racontez dans un livre intitulé
propofol publié chez léochère et ici
maintenant pour nous
alors Philippe vous êtes né à Paris le
26 janvier
1952 parents chirurgien-dentiste les
études faites ce qu'il faut pour arriver
au bac pas plus
ensuite faites la Faculté de Médecine
une spécialité en psychiatrie pendant
quelques années vous êtes psychiatre et
en 1984 vous obtenez donc ce poste à
l'hôpital américain de Neuilly et c'est
là que vous commencez à fréquenter le
gotha c'est exact
difficile évidemment de gérer des
patients riches dorloter qui acceptent
mal la contradiction il faut savoir dire
non c'est à dire que la plupart du temps
il vous donne des ordres ce qui est
l'inverse du rapport qu'on a
généralement avec les médecins
logiquement oui ça se comprend comme ça
alors un jour c'est Sharon Stone qui
vous demande de venir au rite dans un
premier temps vous êtes subjugué par sa
beauté naturelle alors que vous avez vu
plein de stars pas terribles au réveil
elle est belle
elle est sublime alors la conversation
s'engage la conversation dure vous
finissez quand même à un moment par vous
demander pourquoi elle nous a fait venir
depuis le début je me pose la question
et elle vous répond pour rien tout
s'était arrangé quelques minutes avant
votre arrivée et elle n'avait pas annulé
le rendez-vous pour ne pas vous décevoir
oui parce qu'elle me connaissait déjà
elle voulait qu'on se parle il s'est
rien passé
alors être médecin de star c'est aussi
visiter des patients à l'étranger un
jour on vous appelle au chevet d'un
prince saoudien le chèque Salem à
Casablanca au filet à Casablanca pour
aller très vite et là vous dites il
était à lui tout seul une encyclopédie
des pathologies du quatrième âge ce sont
des gens qui sont tellement bien soignés
que ils associent les maladies les unes
après les autres et comme on les soigne
bien ils continuent à vivre ils
continuent à vivre et vivre très
longtemps il avait une patate d'enfer le
chèque capacité vitale considérable
considérable on va voir alors la
première question c'est de se dire
qu'est-ce que fait un prince saoudien à
Casablanca en fait ils viennent pour les
prostituées marocaines quoi tout à fait
oui c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
culturel parce que en Arabie Saoudite ça
a très mauvaise réputation d'aller au
Maroc alors le Gex se plie à l'examen
verticale vous lui faites un
électrocardiogramme ensuite ces dîner
dans le sang alors en fin de repas
arrive des danseuses plus ou moins
majeures on peut bien le dire plus ou
moins majeur et alors le secrétaire du
chèque vous dit allez-y vous pouvez vous
servir
ce sont les règles de l'hospitalité
ouais il faut les respecter et alors ce
qui est incroyable c'est que les invités
du chèque arrivent à 3h du matin et ils
ont tous 70 75 ans quoi oui mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils font debout et cette
heure-là et bien écoutez c'est très
simple pendant la journée ils sont
couchés
à ce moment-là entraîne tout le monde
dans une annexe du palais c'est une
espèce de salle des fêtes en sous-sol il
y a des tables basses et des divans
il y a des graines de tournesol dans des
dans des petites coupelles il y a des
noix de cajou mais aussi du Viagra et du
cialis il y a plus de viagradcialistes
que de noix de cajou
il y a quand même 60 filles qui
pénètrent d'un seul coup dans la salle
voilà faut avoir du carburant
il y a un an qui s'occupe d'elle ça
c'est très intéressant
quand vous dites celle-là le nain c'est
celui qui va la chercher voilà oui tout
à fait c'est vous vous pressé
sélectionnez et sur la sur la scène vous
avez ces 60 jeunes femmes qui dansent de
façon très lasive sur des musiques tout
à fait orientales et le nain il a un
visage très très vicieux
et il a un œil
il a un œil extraordinaire qui se trouve
jamais quand vous dirigez le doigt il
sait exactement ce que vous voulez un
homme qui devance presque vos désirs le
chèque voit que vous manquez un peu dans
le train faut dire faut dire les choses
le chèque est un peu dessus parce que
vous êtes je sais pas sur les gonzesses
c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire que la
première c'est assise à côté de moi on a
commencé un peu à parler
le niveau de conversation c'était
Casablanca les encombrements la météo
c'était des sujets assez neutres donc
vous en prenez une autre avec laquelle
vous faites rien de plus qu'à la
première et alors en partant vous offrez
les gonzesses au secrétaire du chèque
qui normalement il y a pas droit à lui
voilà le personnel n'a pas le droit
voilà et puis les arnaques alors un jour
vous êtes appelés au chevet d'une
cliente qui est victime a priori d'une
indigestion vous arrivez dans la chambre
les rideaux sont tirés il y a une petite
veilleuse vous discerner un corps sous
des couvertures quelques boucles blondes
dépassent sur l'oreiller je vois que
vous avez bien lu ah oui vous vous dites
trop bu je suis perplexe vous l'examinez
rien alors vous dites quand même pour
lui faire plaisir je vais je vais lui
faire une ordonnance voilà ça ça serait
pas venu pour rien vous mettez derrière
le bureau vous commencez à rédiger votre
ordonnance soudain c'est bravo en lasse
elle frotte son corps nu contre le vôtre
je m'en souviens plus ça
elle veut faire l'amour
elle veut pas elle m'attire l'ordre de
ah oui c'est quand même un peu spécial
et là vous dérobez à sa pression elle
s'allonge devant la porte de la chambre
là vous êtes malin vous lui dites on
serait mieux au lit elle se lève elle va
se mettre dans le lit et vous vous fuyez
en fait c'est une gonzesse qui se
croquer les palaces exactement
et après elle demande un million de
d'euros de dommages et intérêts on va
faire de scandale quoi et ça se négocie
à 500000 alors désormais donc vous
devenez le médecin des stars les
directeurs des palaces vous appellent
régulièrement Philippe et un jour le
propriétaire du Ritz Mohamed Al-Fayed
vous appelle il vous dit voilà il y a eu
quand même l'histoire de Diana il y a
madame ariman qui est morte dans la
piscine de l'hôtel
là je reçois Michael Jackson il faudrait
que tu t'en occupes et il vous demande
de faire la nounou de Michael Jackson en
fait absolument une sorte de garde du
corps nous nous pour éviter qu'il y ait
une histoire dans son hôtel pas de
problème bah oui bien sûr alors une
semaine plus tard vous retrouverez en
tête à tête avec Michael Jackson dans sa
suite alors ce qui est incroyable c'est
que la suite est décorée avec des
ballons des cotillons des paillettes
enfin comme pour un anniversaire
d'enfant il passe la nuit
s'endormir et regarde des films de Walt
Disney donc vous êtes obligés de faire
pareil de toute façon vous êtes vous
êtes sa nounou oui et puis il faut que
je sois correct j'ai été payé pour ça
donc il faut que je sois faut pas que je
dorme
il regarde des films il dit pas un mot
regarde des films
ils parlent un peu au début on se disait
pas grand-chose et vous progressivement
on a commencé à échanger et le deuxième
soir vous avez toujours pas dormi il
vous demande d'examiner ses pieds et
vous découvrez les pieds massacrés par
la danse et pas soigner c'est une chose
qu'on voit très souvent chez les
danseurs oui la deuxième nuit pareil
Walt Disney Walt Disney vous dormez pas
non lui non plus non mais en tant que
médecin j'ai quand même l'habitude de ne
pas dormir donc 24 heures ça me fait pas
peur 48 heures je commence à peu près là
je commence à tirer et 72 heures et là
il vous explique un truc il me dit en
fait le fait de pas dormir ça stimule
mon imagination absolument
qui se laisse partir pendant longtemps
comme ça il entend des musiques et après
il les retranscrit quoi voilà l'insomnie
c'est quelque chose de dangereux vous
voyez au bout de quatre ou cinq jours on
peut avoir des troubles mentaux et au
bout d'une semaine on peut mourir donc
c'est quelque chose qui peut être grave
et lui fait ça régulièrement quand il
fait ça que sous forme d'une session
pour pouvoir
composer alors le jour suivant donc vous
êtes toujours là horrible avec Michael
Jackson
il a toujours pas sommeil et il souffre
des pieds et là vous l'envoyer à
l'hôpital américain et le lendemain
matin quand vous le revoyez il vous dit
qu'il a passé une des meilleures nuits
de sa vie tout à fait sur le chemin de
l'hôtel est tellement bien que en
retournant en Ritz il s'arrête à la FNAC
mais sorti de cette limousine Mercedes
Classe S dont vous vous doutez sur le
trottoir avenue Niel et on est rentré
dans la FNAC des Ternes et on est monté
au rayon voilà et là donc les gens c'est
tellement insensé que les gens ne le
reconnaissent pas il y a même un mot qui
dit quel ringard ce mec avec son
déguisement de Michael Jackson
ils le prennent pour un animateur de la
Fnac qui se déguisé en Michael Jackson
alors que moi je suis terrorisé parce
que je me dis qu'on va aller à l'émeutes
et que je ne suis pas garde du corps que
je n'ai aucune capacité de gérer la
situation alors de retour à l'hôtel
Michael Jackson on veut savoir quel est
le médicament qui lui a permis de passer
peut-être la meilleure nuit de sa vie et
c'est le propofol donc qui est un
ingésique c'est ça non oui alors c'est
un médicament c'est un médicament qui
est utilisé uniquement en réanimation et
dans un bloc opératoire
et là pour des raisons que je ne peux
pas expliquer ici ça a été utilisé chez
lui mais dans un cadre tout à fait légal
bien entendu mais il a compris que ce
médicament lui apportait quelque chose
d'autre que la raison pour laquelle on
l'avait utilisé et moi je ne l'ai pas su
à cette époque là mais il a continué de
s'en servir et dix ans après il en a
marre voilà c'est ce que j'appelle le
syndrome Michael Jackson justement c'est
à dire que quand vous êtes riche et
célèbre en fait on vous refuse aucun
médicament et vous finissez par en
mourir le problème pour le médecin c'est
de résister c'est de tenir la route
merci en tous les cas le livre est
vachement bien vraiment très intéressant
merci Philippe et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu